hey what's going on it's bill burns it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah
i'm just checking in on you just
checking in on you
seeing how you doing how your life's
working out
oh you've been since monday if you
listen all the time why do i have this
[ __ ] hat on all right
um sorry anyway um
oh freckles covet negative
negator
negative
so there you go there you have it
i'm part of the statistics
um
you know and i got both shots and i got
the booster so i didn't even know i
[ __ ] had it
unless i tested then i tested i realized
i had i thought i just had a little
scratchy throat there
which happens from time to time
um
but i am calling it the shot from now on
it's not a vaccine a va let me look up a
definition of a vaccine
vaccine doesn't that mean you get it
once and then you can't get the [ __ ]
although i know it was for the 19th not
the omicron it was for the star wars
version not the empire strikes back
there uh vaccine
definition
a substance used to simulate the
production of ant uh of antibodies and
provide immunity against one of several
diseases prepared from the caustic
causticity of agent of the disease its
product or a synthetic substitute
treated to act as an antigen
without inducing the disease okay so
it's still
so it isn't just you get it you're done
how long
should
vaccines
oh wait i got one what's the difference
between a vaccine
and a shot
by the way for all you non-vexers i'm
not microchipped and i didn't grow a
foot where my dick was
whatever dumb [ __ ] you thought was gonna
happen
um immunization
or vaccination what is the difference
let's see let's see
so maybe you can still call it a vaccine
uh how does immunization work the term
banks is this funny this is like
literally what people do and then 10
minutes later they feel like they have a
strong
like argument this is what i'm doing
right now people on both sides do this
let me google this and then i'll google
that and now i'm ready to argue who
wants some
um i don't know what the [ __ ] it is all
i know is i got the shots and uh
i was fine i smoked cigars every day i
had kovit and i felt [ __ ] great
[Laughter]
i've seen the people that didn't get the
[ __ ] and they were [ __ ] gray
uh they did not look so hot oh god dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude i'll tell you you
don't want to get it man you don't want
to get that's all i heard
um
so
plowing ahead um all right so because of
covet i had to reschedule my uh fantasy
fantasy
springs resort date in palm springs
california my apologies
uh for the late cancellation i was
hoping i was to test uh negative but it
did not happen um so there's still a few
tickets left because i know some people
were traveling in to see the show and
they had to give up their tickets i feel
bad about that you can go to
billboard.com um to get for the ticket
links links to some left once again my
apology
apologies to people i don't know i mean
it was beyond
my control um
yeah so there you go um by the way so
even though i've been
really busy lately
i'm trying to put this project together
out here i'm out in hollywood people i'm
developing a project
uh i actually got to watch the third
period of the bruins versus cracking
dragon
look out for the kraken
um
they're kind of a piece of [ __ ] team
they're not fast so they just try to
injure you
it kind of seems how they play
um you know kind of a throwback team
they don't have any wheels they're
expansion teams so it's like all right
you're faster than we are so i guess uh
boarding is on the [ __ ]
it's on the plate i don't know the last
second he turned so it wasn't
um
and then i watched the celtics the uh
last quarter and a half of them beating
the hornets just letting the hornets
hanging around got hornets just kept
playing and we kind of felt like we had
him beat
and um
i don't i like watching the celtics when
i get when i finally get a chance it was
weird my kids were in a decent mood
as far as they they were cool with
watching uh
with watching what they called daddy tv
which is anything that isn't like you
know puppy dog pals that baby spider-man
with the like the brother and sister
spider-man whatever that one's called
um
which is the guy the guy who wrote that
music i just saw is the guy from
panic at the disco i want to say i i
missed that whole decade of music
no fall out boy
fallout boy there you go
the lead singer of that wrote all of
this music and he taught himself like
the trumpet i was watching this whole
thing on it it was [ __ ] amazing
so um
anyway motogp starts this month i think
f1 starts next month
march madness is coming up
it's all good stuff all of it all of it
all of it great news
sports-wise to take my mind off of two
things one
there's only one football game left this
year
bowl you know by the way speaking of the
super bowl
you know i'm a weirdo i went on ebay and
i was looking for afl
football cards
you know to see you know if i could get
a babe pirelli or something like that
why not right what else am i gonna do
read a book you know that ain't
happening this isn't why you tune into
this podcast um
so i was looking that up and
i somehow got into like memorabilia and
all of that [ __ ] and this person is
selling this
super bowl 2
green bay packers button
i want you guys to look this up
because i think it's a fake
they want 700 something dollars for it
it says afl versus nfl and then on the
top it says super bowl
now as far as my knowledge of nfl
football the first two games were called
the nfl afl championship game it was not
called the super bowl until super bowl
three and then retroactively
historically they called
the first two
afl nfl uh championship games super bowl
one and super bowl two but they were not
called that
um and i don't even think that the the
phrase was even coined
until then so i'm sitting there going
like wait a minute is this a fake
i was all excited like i was a sleuth
and then maybe i could have i could have
a side career on fake sports memorabilia
because i have all this [ __ ] useless
knowledge
about that [ __ ] like you ever remember
watching like pawn stars and they'd have
those experts come in on [ __ ] or i like
watching stuff where people tell if it's
like a fake cuban cigar or not that's a
big one for me i like when i see um
uh uh fake guitars
i followed this kid he collects guitars
and he bought this slash
model uh
the snake pit one that had you know
the snake on the on on the outside and
uh going up the neck and all of this
[ __ ]
and uh they didn't make that many of
them so the guitar is worth like i don't
know 15 20 [ __ ] grand
i don't know i don't think you're
welcome to the jungle's gonna sound any
better on that than on a hondo if you
suck like me but anyway that's what they
paid and he found out
it's his excruciating video watching
this guy find out that he blew 15 grand
on a [ __ ] fake
i think i did that too
there was a guy advertising a snare drum
uh
played by john bonham
and i paid i just bought it because i
thought it was then when i got i'm like
how the [ __ ] can i even prove this
system and i finally opened it up
because i've had it for years and i kind
of knew it was a fake and i was nervous
to look at it
and first of all it looks like it's like
a five-inch shell and he always played
what was it no wait he played like a
what was it
six and a half by 14 and this thing was
like i'm like that's a [ __ ] that is
just an old ludwig snare drum
that and they wrote bonham
on the uh
on the drum case
so
i i don't know what to do with the thing
i don't even know i i got to figure out
they gave me like a certificate of
authenticity well all i can tell you is
this
don't ever buy something like that on
the internet i remember one time i tried
this is this obscure prince album
you know that i always heard quest love
talking about and i tried to buy one off
the internet paid all of this [ __ ]
money and the [ __ ] that came to me
and it was some dude in japan i was you
know i was gonna chase the guy down and
get my [ __ ] money back
um
i don't know i don't know where i stand
with counterfeiters there's something
[ __ ] hilarious about it
you know
i think counterfeit money is the only
thing that i really respect
but there is something funny that
somebody is just just
has the talent
to make something that actually looks
like the real thing but isn't
and instead
of just working for the company in a
legit way
they go the pirate route like that like
there's no excitement unless there's
some sort of
stealing involved
um
let me look up something here
the psychology
of a counter
they have one of a serial killer of a
counterfeiter
the counterfeit self the deceptive costs
of faking it
counterfeit self the role of the
counterfeit self
well that's just not saying what you're
thinking right the psychology of
knockoffs owning a counterfeit version
of a desert okay here we go
oh this is why people buy it they're not
saying why they make it
this is how i surf the internet
i come up with weird theories and then
jesus christ look at the [ __ ] legs on
her
um
this website uses cookies oh does it
so does the government i don't
understand why i don't understand it
says accept or reject and i just say
reject like they're not doing it anyway
um it has been argued the desire to own
or at least to be seen to own luxury
goods combined with influencer and
social media driven culture reinforces
the message that the success is measured
by the ownership of material goods has
resulted in a toxic formula and i am out
i'm out
just the whole way that that was [ __ ]
written i'm just like this is just a
[ __ ]
just skimming the surface article
first and not even that i want to know
why
i just i want to talk to a counterfeiter
well you just sat there
everybody thinks i got to go out and
make money they don't really think i
need to make money
you know like literally
that's funny if you're a counterfeiter
what are you been up to making money
[Music]
what are you doing yeah you know i'm in
the paper industry
um
that [ __ ] is fascinating to me
like i cannot imagine
this how scared you are in the [ __ ]
rush
the first time you go out with your
paper
you know
i'd counterfeit one dollar bills
that's why i just go to teddy bars now
kid i would counterfeit one dollar bills
that's kind of rough though
i know why they don't do it but i just
figured no one would be success
expecting that but then you would just
so flood the market with these one
dollar bills every time you bought
something for a grant
no this is what you do your partner in
crime has big fake tits
all right and she goes into the bank
every week with the garbage bag
full of these one dollar bills you
create a fake w-2
at the local titty bar and they you know
from some you know titty bar that
doesn't exist
or whatever right to the cayman island
or some [ __ ] right an offshore titty bar
sorry i'm not the best of this and she
just goes in
and she drops the sack down
and then she doesn't withdraw it right
and then you just have like the atm card
and then you just you just work on that
right
and here's the thing she's a real
stripper
that's it she's a real [ __ ] stripper
so then what i do is you know
10 of her [ __ ]
at that point i might as well be doing
fives and twenties but i feel like
they're gonna figure don't take it to a
bank they're gonna figure it out stupid
idea
stupid [ __ ] idea
okay this is what you do
you get a [ __ ] stripper right
you ask her what do you make on any
given night
what do you make and she tells you what
you make or what the best dancer makes
and she goes in there when the dancer
isn't looking she switch out
the uh the dancers
you know
real money with the fake money that i
make
and then she'd take it down to the bank
and she'd immediately get caught and she
said i got it at work and then they
would set up cameras then we'd get
caught [ __ ] this is hard
all right whatever i'll get back to you
on that one
um
anyway but while i'm kind of avoiding
the uh the biggest subject of the week
is
uh unless you want to talk about real
[ __ ] that [ __ ] world's too depressing
just in the world of like i don't want
to pay attention to real [ __ ]
so i'm gonna pay attention to other [ __ ]
tom brady
the greatest
nfl quarterback of all time
not only does he call it quits he does
it in such a classy way i thought
didn't make a big to-do about it or any
of that [ __ ] nobody knew it was his last
game just announces it on on was it
instagram or some [ __ ]
uh i thought it was great and i thought
all those pats fans that had you know
there wasn't too many
like um
i read one woman said she was
heartbroken
that he didn't thank them it's like
heartbroken
heartbroken
the guy goes out there he wins six super
bowls he puts us on the [ __ ] map
nobody has more super bowls than us
before that
everybody who had us any everybody had
at least as little as we did or is or
more than us before he came and by the
time he was done with us nobody had more
than us
that's unfucking believable
and you're heartbroken because he didn't
send you a hallmark card
it but once again it was a very small
portion of the population but that's all
the sports news media needs and then
they started acting like that was all
patriots fans
i got to be honest with you he didn't
even owe me a statement
if he just didn't come back where's tom
brady are you retired ah good for him
good for him he's got all that money
he's already down in florida it's
[ __ ] perfect
good for him
um that's a big thing with me i love
seeing people retire
i'll i'm so [ __ ] happy for him
i'm retired
i'm done can you imagine that
let's say you're you're tom brady's age
what 44 years old and let's just say
you're retired now look obviously you
got to do something you go out of your
[ __ ] mind
all right
but how long would you not do [ __ ] for
if you had if you had like a superstar
athlete's money
you know
i mean
here's here's the deal men that make the
money that he has
if they didn't have a woman in their
life they they could not work ever again
so the key is is to have a woman that
actually is
has a career
which he does so i think i think they're
good
that would be the [ __ ]
44 years of age what are you doing i'm
just going to hang around and watch my
kids grow up
fantastic
i think he thinks he's going to have a
sandwich now some bread
go down to subway i don't know i don't
know what but um
i think like everything he did it was
perfect was perfect the way he retired
and i think it's uh was the perfect time
to go
and um
you know you saw the things
that everybody said he did i hope
somebody mentioned the fact i've never
seen an a superstar athlete
after they leave the team that they win
championships with and they air quote
hang on
for the last couple years i've never
seen one go out win a championship and
in their final year
lead the league in uh
passing in in uh was in yardage and
touchdowns or something like that
his last year in the league he threw for
over 5 000 yards he never
dipped
for 22 nfl seasons it should have been
sad this should have been people saying
he's hanging on too long and all of that
[ __ ] never
[ __ ] he could have played again
another year
unreal unfucking believable so i figured
that's the one that people probably
didn't bring up out of all the things
that they've talked about all his all
his records and all that so uh
you know jesus christ
unfucking believable i wonder how many
co how many quarterbacks
came and went
that if you looked like starting
quarterbacks beginning of every year
that he played
i mean he was right at right he came in
right when elway mourinho went out
and uh
let's see i'm trying to think something
he caught the end of troy aikman i think
treyman might have left before him
i always forget if troy had been played
into the 2000s or not
but i know like uh who else was still
around brett favre was obviously still
around
ah jesus christ dan pastorini i don't
know i don't [ __ ] my brain i don't
i'm not good with quarterbacks back
donovan mcnabb
or the amount of people that had careers
within his career
you know like eli manning started after
him retired before him
peyton manning started a few years
before and then like
i think uh brady played like another
seven seasons beyond it the longevity is
incredible i'm i'm predicting he's gonna
make a whole bunch of money off that
tb12
just within professional athletes
because i think all of them no one wants
to retire and you want to stay
competitive
he's got some sort of system going on
over there that seems to work
um
who knows maybe i'll do tb12 and finally
fix my [ __ ] shoulders
um all right with that let's read um
so congratulations tom brady you did
everything
and as a pats fan it was so awesome to
see you go out on such a high note
and uh
and i'm really happy for you that you're
retired and you don't have to deal with
any more [ __ ]
um all right
i got one read this week butcher box
everyone
butcher box meal prepping is difficult
butcher box makes it easy butcher box is
a subscription service that takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
meat butcher box sources their meat from
partners with the highest standards for
quality beef no more searching the
grocery store for 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken and wild
caught it uh seafood you don't know what
it's gonna do and more
their sourcing decisions are made
holistically keeping the farmer the
planet the animal and your family in
mind
i love knowing what i know love knowing
that i'm putting quality food
out for my family
every month butcher box ships and i'll
be honest with you i don't even think
what i'm doing here every month butcher
box ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to your home free
ship free shipping for the continental
united states no antibiotics
or added hormones no squirrel meat like
those fast food joints each box contains
8 to 14 pounds of meat depending on the
box you choose that's enough for 24
individual meals
packed fresh and shipped frozen for
convenience so you can save time on your
next grocery store trip this is your
chance to never have to shop for ground
beef again that's right butcher box is
giving new members free ground beef for
life sign up at
butcherbox.com and get two pounds of
ground beef in every order for the life
of your membership log on to
butcherbox.com
burr b-u-r-r claim this deal
all right
there we go so
anyways
anyways anyway
one of these days i'm gonna get that
right
any anyway um
i've been on the [ __ ] actor diet i
got an acting gig coming up so uh
oh billy freckles billy freckles is
moving down the notches on his belt
knocking down the covid weight um
i did the sound mix on my new special
very excited about that next i do the
[ __ ] color
we do the color oh billy blue eyes
coming out for one more dance of [ __ ]
and dick jokes
um
i'm very excited about this one i kind
of haven't seen it in like a month and a
half so i kind of had like fresh eyes
looking at the thing
and uh i am very very
very excited i think it's my best work
i am very uh anxious for you guys to see
it so all we got to do is just uh
colorize this thing send it over to the
good folks at netflix
and then they'll decide
out of the [ __ ] blue
when it comes on
um that's basically how it works and in
the meantime
i'm going down to the comedy still
because i gotta i gotta work on my [ __ ]
here i gotta make sure or go over to the
laugh factory or the [ __ ] improv
right i gotta figure or maybe uh
someplace in the valley who knows
who the [ __ ] knows waiting for the ice
house to reopen out there in pasadena
over to flappers
the l.a comedy club i love them all
where's the other one the uh the
supernova
i don't give a [ __ ]
um
you know what i'd love to do i'd love to
buy a small theater out here like a
hundred seater
you know
i think that's the way to do it and just
build your hour that way
you know
give away the [ __ ] show people show
up
right well i got to pay rent well it
depends on how cheap i get it you know
how [ __ ] up the seats are
and then every time i want to put
together a new hour i just go down there
for like a week
do two shows a night and just puke it
out and start to form it i would think
after a couple of weeks i'd have
something
that was worthy of then taking it over
to the store and all of that [ __ ] and
then going out on the road
but um
you know there's been a number of
theaters out here
that you know i've performed at
over the years that i loved and then
they just they [ __ ] disappear it
sucks
there was one uh the no name theater
it's the first place i met josh adam
myers first place i jammed with them
it was this great theater it was right
around the corner from another place
that doesn't exist anymore cascade
studios where they used to always
play drums down there they used to rent
them out
you know they just had a drum kit a dw
kit set up in every room and i got to
know the guy joe that ran it down there
and he would let me [ __ ] go into the
showcase for like 20 bucks for the hour
he always hooked me up
um
but uh
yeah
i've been thinking about there's got to
be something
like maybe in the valley or some [ __ ] i
don't know what anyways let's let's
finish this thing up here
um i don't have a lot to talk about
because my life is just been [ __ ]
work lately
um and trying to eat well
getting ready for this thing someday you
know when this [ __ ] thing comes out
i'm gonna tell you guys all about the uh
the whole process
of making [ __ ] out here like yep just
the amount of [ __ ] work is just
it's staggering i don't understand why
when i when i [ __ ]
put in news
it immediately goes to google news see
that guy jeff zucker resigns from cnn
after a relationship with top executive
it was a consensual relationship
why do you have to tell people that
you're banging someone at work
why is that
hang on a second
murdered officer
officers lieutenant says enough is
enough slams california's woke narrative
in eulogy
there we go here comes the pushback
gonna get a little more balanced
it's gonna be a little more battle
wouldn't say fair balance if you've done
fox news but i think
i think it's gonna be more balanced here
um let's see here let's see here where
is the news google news i like i like i
like going with google news for some
reason if i see yahoo news i'm like [ __ ]
that news
i like the google news
google news headline top stories here we
go nod to jay leno here taken right from
the headlines jeff zucker resigns over
consensual relationship with a key
lieutenant
did you bang that lieutenant uh yes yes
i did
did they want you to uh yes
yes they did
how dare you i'm sorry i resigned okay
um i guess it was a bunch of other [ __ ]
that happened too but he resigns as head
of cnn citing failure to disclose a
consensual relationship with a colleague
that says to me other [ __ ] was going on
and he wants to control the narrative
who's gonna [ __ ] quit a job
because she started banging one of you
lieutenant why is there a lieutenant at
a [ __ ]
news organization
because we're fighting the war on
information
um
winter storm threatens a 2 000 mile
stretch of the united states
heavy snow falling as storm system
threatens to leave a treacherous mix of
wintry precipitation for millions from
the plains to the northeast well it's
the winner
what did they think was going to happen
uh pence's document to be turned over to
january 6 committee national archives
says
oh jesus is that [ __ ] still going on are
they still yelling about that keg party
gone wrong the restraint crowd
face palms over biden's ukraine threats
is that like written by a professional
journalist the restraint crowd face
palms
oh smacks themselves in the head over
biden's ukraine threats oh yeah
according to one of our listeners he's
trying to protect his son's job where he
gets a million dollars a year for not
even showing up
[ __ ] bum
a legend the [ __ ] alleged bum
the alleged [ __ ] bum there you go see
that's how you don't get sued u.s and
nato don't budge in answering russian's
demands
are we really going to do this child
[ __ ] again
i wish all americans both the red and
the blue would all show up outside the
white house and all those buildings and
just start chanting grow up
[Laughter]
grow up grow up grow up you know or
whether we're going to war with those
guys yeah no we're not no
you know what buddy you do it you do it
why don't you have a f you have a fight
to the death
with the other world leader who who
would you take
vladimir putin
versus [ __ ] um
joe biden now i know a lot of people
you're like oh my god
any russian versus [ __ ]
our thousand-year-old [ __ ] president
here
you know i know that's what you're
thinking but
i don't know putin likes a rigged game i
think he would have a bunch of tune-up
fights where guys would pretend to box
him the way uh
they pretend to play hockey against him
and i know he's got some sort of like
judo black belt or something like that
but isn't you think it's like uh the
elvis black belt
like dennis miller made fun of a long
time ago one of my favorite
references of all time said so and so
deserved that award as much as elvis
deserved his black belt was [ __ ]
incredible
um hang on a second from the black and
white special one of my favorites of all
time
vladimir putin
martial arts
let's see what he's got
what type of martial arts does putin
know
uh
he's he's educated in the ancient form
of poison mist
sprayed at you when you have a heart
attack
um
what martial arts
how am i in it judo
okay he knows judo let's this is the
tale of the tape
vlad
i'm gonna do the whole [ __ ] hbo thing
vladimir
putin
height
weight
height and weight let's see
let's see he is 168 centimeters oh come
on an american
no he doesn't look too healthy either
it's like he drinks a lot of vodka god
it's got to be fun to be the [ __ ]
head of russia huh
best vodka in the goddamn world all
those hot chicks over there
oh wait a minute he's five foot six
weighs 152 pounds lean and mean blue
eyes of course
blue-eyed devil running the country hair
color salt and pepper
born in 1952 65 he looks great i hate to
say it as an american son of a [ __ ]
looks great all right joe biden
height and weight
age
all right taylor the tape
so we got five foot six 152 65 years old
going up against
joe biden what do we got here come on
with all the [ __ ] ads you [ __ ]
he's six feet tall he's got a half a
foot on the son of a [ __ ]
he weighs 158
so he makes weight he's still a [ __ ]
middleweight
this fight is still on
oh here's the big one he's 77.
deep blue eyes another blue eyed devil
with gray spooky hair okay i think
somebody's [ __ ] on him here he has a
slim body build
build up with the charming smile
his net worth is only 1.5 million
that's about as honest as it gets you
watch that balloon during his presidency
he did really well in the private sector
so who do you like a 77 year old six
foot guy
or a five foot six
five foot six
152 65 and he knows judo let's see joe
biden martial arts
let's see
well he's old let's say boxing
boxing martial arts what do we got here
trump vs biden who would win in an mma
fight
punchy biden look-alike granddad goes
viral for fighting boxing does joe biden
know any martial arts well yes he does
if you want to expand the usual
definition of martial arts
he's quite an expert in the martial art
of verbal judo oh that was clubber that
was clever all right
that's [ __ ] hilarious they got dana
white standing between the two of them
all right who would win
who would win
who gives a [ __ ]
um i'd have to go with the five foot six
inch guy that drinks [ __ ] vodka and
knows judo and it can at least skate you
know
this is the thing i think the biggest
[ __ ] thing
for vladimir putin and he's he wouldn't
want joe biden to get his hands on him
i just feel like he would do that old
man thing where he would bite down and
grit his teeth
maybe growl a little bit
you know have that old man [ __ ] dust
bowl strength
you know
i don't know it looks like putin's been
hitting the [ __ ] bottle man at least
in that picture dude
it's definitely looking a little uh a
little blotchy
jesus christ you ca how big would that
[ __ ] pay-per-view be
let's say it's not a fight to the death
if they just fought each other
god that would be sad they have to be
clothed they got it they got to come in
wearing geese
nobody wants to see those torsos right
all right i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about at this point
um all right i got one for you guys
anybody out there got like a a degree in
uh what do they call what was that what
was that stupid degree where you studied
government in college
all right i want you to rank
the world leaders as far as the toughest
if they if they had to get in the
octagon
like i want you to make up a bracket and
i want you to tell me who's going to win
and why
um and if you guys want to weigh in tell
me who's your duke who's your ucla who's
your kentucky
um i got to admit like back in the day
like
it's weird there's a difference between
being ruthless and putting people to
death and then actually fighting
somebody you know
because oh fatty cakes out there in
north korea
right
i mean i heard he fed his uncle to dogs
like naked because he thought he was
trying to portray him but that myself
might also be u.s propaganda who knows
who the [ __ ] knows right
but that guy like i don't know if he's
ever [ __ ]
whacked anybody
so that's a big thing with me
you know as far as the intangibles if
you got a couple of kills under your
belt um
you know age obviously
like saddam hussein
would have been a good guy to bet on
you know like that guy seems like he he
would like you
know just imagine him with his eyes all
[ __ ] wide like the undertaker man
that would be some scary [ __ ] you know
that full head of hair and that [ __ ]
magnum pi mustache coming at you
um
you know in a perfect world when they
all like would get like overthrown
they would then join this [ __ ] over
60 wrestling thing
like wrestling federation and vince
mcmahon could have it
you know over 65 like it's 60 if you
make it to 65 without getting whacked
right you automatically should have to
step down as the leader of a country and
then you just join
that wrestling federation
that's how you earn your money rather
than going on a speech door that's how
you get your mansion
in martha's vineyard
you know i got one other show idea for
you guys
all right you know that show big brother
you do the canceled celebrity version of
that
and you have dr drew hosted and you have
all these canceled celebrities go in
there and the whole competition is they
have to become like better people
and in the end you got to figure out
who's not lying who actually gives a
[ __ ]
that you know they did whatever they did
they're not all going to be gems people
all right whatever can you tell them
overtired i don't give a [ __ ] all right
once again congratulations to tom brady
um
unbelievable career just unbelievable
and thank you
football gods for bringing him to new
england
um i don't think you're ever going to
see a run like that again
for that long and that many titles uh
and if someone's gonna do i i would love
to see that get broken because i love
seeing
seeing uh greatness and hopefully the
guide plays for the pats
um all right that's it
everybody uh who do you like who do you
like in the super bowl
i you know the spread came out it's only
three points i think the uh the rams are
favored by three
i don't know i got this weird [ __ ]
feeling about the bengals i just have a
weird feeling
that they're gonna do it
i don't know why
i don't know why versions got me
thinking about their offensive line i
have no idea but uh anyways uh that's
the podcast listen to the bet mgm
segment oh there is not one this week
because there's no game so just enjoy
the music and enjoy this next half hour
of a bonus uh thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
have a great weekend and thank you to
everybody who switched your plans
to come out to my fantasy spring states
uh i'm going to go extra hard extra
extra hard on that show all right that's
it i'll see you
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
monday uh
february 3rd
2014. how the hell are you how's it
going i'm a little bit handicapped this
week because my internet isn't working
i don't know why
i don't know what happened i hit the
little reset button you know you take
out the little pin
and you stick it in the side you do a
little [ __ ] five count
and you sit there staring at the goddamn
lights
blinky blinky blinky and then what
happens huh it's supposed to all be good
well not this week i don't have any so
if you think my reading is bad when i'm
reading it off a nice giant computer
screen
where do you hear this week when i'm
reading off my [ __ ] iphone
oh wait till you hear it
spoiler alert
um
all right well let's get down to it how
about that [ __ ] super bowl
was that awesome or what
i'm speaking as a patriots fan by the
way um
i gotta be honest like if peyton manning
won his second super bowl
and uh then he had two and brady had
three then that stupid-ass debate is
gonna start again
which i have not heard since peyton uh
lost
i should say the colts lost when they
played the saints and i didn't want to
[ __ ] hear it
all right
and i love it so all you uh peyton
manning fans for all these years you've
been telling me that [ __ ] peyton's
better than brady
look how many yards he had in [ __ ]
october
um
you know it was a classic
a classic uh peyton manning stat
yesterday is despite the fact
that they got the living [ __ ] kicked out
of him
he still set the record for most
completions in a super bowl game right
he completed 33 passes
33 passes so you got to be like jesus
christ what'd he throw for 500 yards
at least 33
you know what he threw for 280 yards
that's less than nine yards a catch it
was eight point something yards a catch
dinking and dunking down the damn field
and he got half those [ __ ] yards
in the uh the end of the third quarter
when seattle went to like a [ __ ]
prevent just gave him the middle of the
field
and gave him those six [ __ ] points
which pissed me off i wanted him to shut
him out
right it's embarrassing how much i root
against peyton because i it's like it
has nothing to do with the guy i think
he's a great [ __ ] quarterback i was
just what i really i'm doing as i'm
hating on peyton is if i can be am i too
white to use that expression as i
dislike
peyton manning is i am um
um it's it's really just all the sports
fans that i've run into over the years
who just
with peyton manning it was always
individual stats and then blaming
everybody around them
the coaching the defense the writing
game
all that [ __ ] crap give me a goddamn
break
give me
a [ __ ] break did you see that look on
his face about three quarters of the way
through the first quarter
in my family that is known as payton
face and that's when he starts pouting
and he gets frustrated and he gets upset
and you can't have your [ __ ] leader
looking like that now nobody on espn's
gonna say it none of them are gonna
[ __ ] say that [ __ ] because they
[ __ ] drop down at the stats god and
suck its dick every day on [ __ ]
sports center they don't watch the game
all right none of those people on espn
are even human beings they walk in as
human beings
right and then something happens they
drill into their head and they stick a
chip in there and then they just become
like these
you know like i don't think i don't
think like their lips should move i
think like their jaws should just open
and close like one of those wooden
puppets
you know those ones that are dressed
like those guards they're in the
nutcrackers
right that's what that's what the one
they gonna do
right
right they should just be doing that
[ __ ]
i think i'd rather a
guy um
i can't even tell you i had no idea how
hard i was rooting for seattle
until the game
[ __ ] started because i thought you
know as you guys all know how much i
hated that stupid 12th man
and like you know what have been a great
drinking game was how many times joe
buck said it was really loud here
right
with the stupid sound of meter
and all of that [ __ ] and i actually got
a lot of people on on twitter were
giving me [ __ ] going yeah how how dumb
do you feel now i never [ __ ] on seattle
i never said they were a bad team if you
listen to my podcast
you dumb [ __ ]
i said it was yours to lose i bet on you
guys to win it
but that doesn't change and even your
championship does not change that that
12th man thing and everybody dressing up
like characters and bringing [ __ ] uh
new year's
whistles to the goddamn game is not the
dumbest thing that i've embarrassing
embarrassing ball washing thing i've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life the 12th
man stinks
you have nothing to do with the victory
despite what the players and the owners
are gonna say they all make millions
because of your dumb asses
that's why they're saying nice [ __ ] to
you
all right
jesus [ __ ] christ
do we think there's some running back in
the other huddle as he's listening to
the play going you know i'd really like
to execute this play the way we have all
week in practice but golly
golly is that crowd loud
um but congratulations
to the true fans of the seattle seahawks
the real ones the real ones the ones who
showed up when they sucked too the ones
who when they got better didn't go out
and buy a bunch of [ __ ] and start
dressing up like [ __ ] a green ben
franklin or whatever the [ __ ] those
people were doing in the stands
um i gotta ask you be honest seattle
seahawks fans
now that you actually have something to
crow about pun intended you know don't
now you actually have a super bowl
trophy you guys are actually champions
you can actually sing we are the
champions
now doesn't that loud thing seem a
little [ __ ] ridiculous
didn't that just kind of seem
like you know that mother that can't
admit that our kid's not talented
so they gotta like somehow come up with
everybody gets a trophy
everybody gets a ribbon you know
what you guys have created up there
i hope is over
not as far as like your run on on
championships i'd never wish that
against you but as far as that loud
horseshit
um
if kansas city next year tries to break
the record again if that whole [ __ ]
thing starts like who is the loudest
crowd and i guarantee you it will
i can't say again i wouldn't surprise me
if it would it is embarrassing
you have your super bowl trophy for the
love of [ __ ] god
please
stop looking each other in the street
going 12th man
okay
was that really even a congratulations i
was uh
i was losing my [ __ ] mind
watching that game i absolutely love
people i guess didn't like the game or
whatever thought it was boring i
[ __ ] loved that game
that that game was the biggest [ __ ]
beat down i'm trying to think if it was
as bad
this is bad for like bronco fans i'm not
rubbing this in
this really has to this goes back to the
patriots colts like 10 [ __ ] years ago
when brady had three rings and payton
had none and they were going i'll tell
you about you know i know brady's got
the rings but uh
if i got a star team i got a building
around this guy he's got all the
intangibles
right
he's [ __ ] losing
every year
in the first goddamn round
um anyways but last one i hope you guys
and i hope um people who didn't give a
[ __ ] about the game i hope you um
you took my advice
and you let the game go for 90 minutes
90 minutes
is the magic number
that is the magic number if you want to
avoid everything and actually watch the
game and be on the edge of your [ __ ]
seat
provided if it's a good game
is you let it go for 90 minutes
90 minutes
you're hanging outside you're drinking
beers you're doing whatever the [ __ ]
you're doing hanging with like three
four other people tops
who are also into the game
all right we come in we sit down
and we just start when everybody shut
their phones off so we don't know
anything right press play
and then for the rest of the game we
didn't watch one commercial
we didn't have to sit through one
challenge flag anytime anybody got hurt
we fast forward to it we fast forward
through the entire [ __ ] halftime show
didn't see any of it all we saw was the
game and the second it ended
and the coaches were walking out and
they're going all right we'll get out of
the field we'll pick shut we shut the
[ __ ] game off
didn't watch one second
on espn
nothing
i'm guaranteeing you
everybody there was going that's like
one of the most enjoyable super bowl
experiences i ever had it was [ __ ]
great any time they cut down to pam
oliver or that other chick you just fast
forward
the whole [ __ ] it was tremendous
absolutely tremendous
um but anyways let's talk about the
[ __ ] game
so anyways the rest of the world is 90
minutes ahead of us and we're still
downstairs
um
you know out my back yard
smoking a pork
shoulder
right i made one of my famous apple pies
law heads [ __ ] killing it on my grill
you want to talk about losing your man
card i had another man come over my
house and smoke a pork shoulder on my
grill
i couldn't believe i woke up this
morning my wife was still next to me
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you realize like in the south like i
would legally be considered a homosexual
if i did something like that i knew it i
[ __ ] knew it ever since i'm telling
you right now ain't no man who likes
himself a piece of [ __ ] allows another
man to come over [ __ ] smoke on his
grip
grilling that's okay smoking that's a
whole other thing you know what i'm
saying
i wouldn't be surprised if not only if
he's one of them them uh uh
uh
homeotopsexuals if he's also one of them
terrorists
he's probably building a dirty bomb
shaped like a dick that's all i'm saying
um
[Laughter]
yeah i just you know
one of the keys to being successful in
life is knowing what you suck at and
then being able to find talent in that
area and then delegating
that's what you do but delegating you
have to be you like you got to be
careful though you can't delegate so
much of your job that you're just
sitting in your office twiddling your
thumbs because then you're [ __ ]
useless
there's a fine line
between putting a team together
and then just sitting in a [ __ ] room
like a uh like a [ __ ]
like a goddamn mop
so i still made an apple pie i put on an
apron
took out some flour and some sugar
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm good at making
desserts
all right
i don't know it's embarrassing but i i
like sweets
and my mom always made great pies and
when i moved out i missed them so i
learned how to make them [ __ ] sue me
um
oh jesus
i can't even look myself in the mirror
after this [ __ ] podcast
what do you want from me people i i'm
flying blind here
all right i don't have the internet i'm
doing a podcast without the internet
this is like a pilot flying at night
without his instrument panel
am i in a spin am i am i level with the
horizon i don't know am i going up my
going down
god i wish i had a beverage so i could
actually look at it to try to figure out
which way i'm going isn't that what you
do
you just put like a glass of water on
the on the airplane's dashboard and then
you just you just use that as your
[ __ ] horizon
come on man that's pretty ingenious for
a comedian
who has zero hours
up in the air
um
anyway so let's get back to the game so
the entire world is like
90 minutes ahead of us and there's
something cool about that right like
they all got on the spaceship and they
went to a better planet and we all sat
back like yeah go [ __ ] yourself we're
toughing it out here
gnawing on cigars and [ __ ] pretending we
know how to fight right so we go
upstairs and they finally like you guys
want to watch the game yeah yeah let's
[ __ ] watch it all right so we go
upstairs we put it on
i fast forward like you know get right
to where right before the kicker is
going to kick the ball and i hit pause
you guys ready everybody's like yeah
we're ready let's go boom [ __ ] kicks
the ball off
right broncos get the ball and the very
first play from scrimmage
all right peyton calls an audible
the [ __ ]
manny ramirez who i thought you know
when you get kicked out of baseball i
didn't think that you could then just go
play football but once again jesus what
a [ __ ]
talent this man is manny b and manny
hikes the ball
over peyton's [ __ ] head
into the goddamn end zone whatever the
guy falls on it they get a safety very
first play
from scrimmage and i'm not going to lie
to you
i literally put my hand over my mouth
and i was stunned
absolutely stunned
because uh you know i'm not gonna lie to
you you know you guys know what my
prediction was last week i thought that
game was gonna be a classic um i knew
the afc was weaker
i definitely kind of felt that seattle
49ers might have been the super bowl but
it's [ __ ] peyton manning
and i knew seattle had a great defense
and all that
i just thought it was going to be
back and forth
um
through the first half
this is what i thought and i thought it
would maybe one one team of the yellow
was going to be up by like two three
points maybe four at the half
and then in the second half
i thought that the broncos defense was
gonna cave and that marshawn lynch was
gonna [ __ ] run all over him
that obviously
did not happen
i think the broncos went in there all
right obviously we're like all right we
got to stop we got to stop marshawn
lynch and they did
they did and they were like that wilson
guy is not playing well
if we're going to get beat by our
offense it's going to be with that guy's
[ __ ] um
and other than a couple
overly excited throws
you know where he overthrew that guy
right out there in the flat other than
that that kid [ __ ] settled down and
had the game of his life i thought he he
made some great [ __ ] throws
had no picks no fumbles no nothing he
did not hurt the team all he did was
move it forward he played a great
[ __ ] game
dude it was total
100
[ __ ] domination
i mean think about that they had two
field goals
they had a safety
they had a touchdown offensive touchdown
i think it was a run right yeah marshawn
lynch that was a run
that's 20 what two field goals at six
how [ __ ] annoying is this me going
through the whole game that's 20 points
no that isn't
oh here's the comedy trying to add this
up right three and three is six plus
seven is thirteen plus two is fifteen
they had a k special teams kickoff
return
that was [ __ ] 22.
what else did they i don't [ __ ] run
they had a pick six
that's 29 points
then they scored another 14. i don't
even [ __ ] remember
and i'm telling you i mean i might be
wrong but they could have shut them out
they went into the prevent and at the
end of the third quarter which was
[ __ ] brilliant
just give up the middle of the field
let them burn out the rest of this
[ __ ] quarter and we're up even if
they score a touchdown we're still up by
almost 30 points there's no [ __ ] way
they're scoring 30 in the fourth quarter
it was over i've never seen the starting
quarterback
get taken out of the game like well
there's no sense risking you getting
injured
in a [ __ ] super bowl i can't i'm
trying to think
did they take troy aikman out that year
when they uh
they won like 50 something to whatever
against buffalo or did they take joe
montana out
um
in that 55 to 10 game i don't think jim
mcmahon came out when they beat the [ __ ]
out of the patriots that 46 to 10 game
so this is what i'm doing during the
game
this is how much of a psycho i am
every time seattle scored points
i stood up and i high-fived each person
i was watching the game with every time
i'd go tom brady tom brady
tom brady tom brady as i was going
around the [ __ ] room
[Laughter]
i just
look i'm too dumb to follow politics
i'm not good at math
i don't understand science
so sports is all i have
so when i put on espn it has been an
absolute dream for me since
2010 to not listen to the who is better
peyton or tom brady and if he won
yesterday
i was gonna have to [ __ ] listen to
that again so this is completely just
selfish
totally selfish
because i didn't give a [ __ ] about
seattle either and there would have been
nothing funnier than after all that
screaming and yelling if they didn't win
it the whole [ __ ] thing i mean i
didn't give a [ __ ]
it would have been hilarious but the
second the game started like when
seattle started playing well
first i saw peyton right and then there
was the safety
and i was like i was literally nervous
at the beginning of the game going oh my
god
is he gonna just carve up this [ __ ]
unbelievable defense
and then this argument's gonna start
again
i'm making this whole super bowl about
me i realize this this was all this is
all i gave a [ __ ] about
and then um
and then seattle started doing well and
i started seeing you know pete carroll
very surprisingly i don't think i saw
him went whoa the whole game i don't
think i saw him do that once
but i got it and then i was looking at
him like ah [ __ ] pete carroll
i don't want to see this guy win like i
was just [ __ ] i was like this little
gargoyle in the corner
just sitting there like is there any way
both teams could lose so i could be
satisfied as a sports fan i was just
like one of the biggest [ __ ] that ever
watched a [ __ ] game
um and then i just realized that it was
mo it was more about uh
oh yeah and not only that
versi picked the broncos
and i picked seattle
and that's uh back-to-back years where
paul versi has been dead [ __ ] wrong
and uh this is the thing about paul and
this is why you should never
ever and you can you can call in the
versi effect if he has callers and you
can tell him i said this don't ever
ever take gambling advice from that man
i'm not saying he's a good guy
i'm not saying he's not a stand-up guy
i'm not saying he's got a great husband
and father
not saying he's not a great comedian i'm
just talking about the gambling part
of paul verzi's
new jersey brain
via new york
all right
that [ __ ] guy
he's never gonna learn
he is that guy loves offense
it's a cliche at this point to say
defense wins championships
paul just he can't hear it
paul's like that guy that's had [ __ ]
19 beers
and he's and you're trying to go give me
your keys and he just will always think
that he can drive
that's what he is
i hope he listens to this
when it comes
to being a gambler that [ __ ] guy
loves
he's flash he likes the flash
he likes pinky rings offense throw the
bomb
that's his big thing air it out scare
the defense he loves it waste of play
just throw it 70 [ __ ] yards
he is he's a times square
[ __ ] kind of guy he likes the lights
he loves the [ __ ] offense
i on the other hand am a miserable
middle-aged annie andy rooney [ __ ] so i
of course love defense i love a 10 to 7
game
i love it
[Music]
i love it when people sit there so
[ __ ] boring i absolutely love it i
love a pictures duel
i don't know
why
i know why because i'm the kind of guy
that will watch a super bowl and root
for both teams to lose
um so anyways congratulations in all
seriousness congratulations to the fans
of seattle uh that's got to be it's
great you guys haven't [ __ ] won
a championship when was it let's see 77
was the bullets
no 77 was portland 78 was the bullet 79
i believe was uh the super sonics
um
the loudest fans they are the loudest
fans hey uh seattle seahawks fans do you
ever think if you cheered that loud for
the sonics they wouldn't have left
oh
it's just never going to get old teasing
them they don't give a [ __ ] they have a
championship parade
so now they're actually talking because
they're so young i mean dude that was
[ __ ] that was seriously i know i'm
still breaking their balls just because
it's fun
um
that was seriously one of
i knew the afc is weak but i mean
they're only so weak that was still
peyton manning with one of the most
prolific offenses in the history of the
modern era [ __ ] the whole game because
the game has changed so much but like
um
jesus christ
i mean that game was over over
in like
even i who nev i always say it's never
over it's never over it's never over
even
i mean it was just it was [ __ ] over
the [ __ ] game was over
joe bartnick was sitting on my couch
just laugh he started laughing
in the uh
when the guy was ran the [ __ ] ball
back
to start the second half
because he's sitting there going like
what did he say he said bill he goes i'm
glad you have money on this game
because if you didn't i would be back
outside drinking
and i start laughing and then you know
and as we're doing that we're fast
forwarding through all the [ __ ] you
know
um
halftime show
and as he's saying that i'm laughing we
hit pause everybody you know bathroom
break and then we hit play
they kick the ball off and the dude
starts running back and and
bartnik has this high-pitched laugh i
just see him going
this guy runs the [ __ ] thing back
dude it was an absolute beat i i have to
think that everybody in washington the
state of washington has to have
laryngitis
like
for [ __ ] especially if you watch the
game and you didn't miss any commercials
you just watched it like like a nerd and
just sat there like a good little
[ __ ] tv viewer and you watched the
whole halftime show i mean everybody in
the state of washington has to have
laryngitis
i'm trying to think the only
disappointment you had
was that you didn't shut them out
and even then it was just like that was
they did that on purpose
they just gave up the middle of the
field jesus bill how many [ __ ] times
are you gonna we got it they gave up the
middle of the field you [ __ ]
oh
you know who would have thought i'd be
so [ __ ] elated to see pete carroll
win a championship i just it just
he protect there was a couple of [ __ ]
things this week i didn't hear it but i
guess on bill simmons podcast he
interviewed larry byrne and
larry bird they asked him who he would
want to play with the most in today's
nba and he said kobe bryant
kobe bryant he just said no the guy
plays hurt he just [ __ ] just went on
and on about how awesome the guy was so
i have to retire trashing kobe bryant
it took larry bird to let me know that i
was wrong
but isn't that why you listen to the
podcast doesn't it make you feel better
about yourself i know it's funny but i'm
so [ __ ] arrogant i still don't think
i'm wrong about that guy
um
i i can't get past my blind hatred of
the [ __ ] it's not even the lakers
it's their [ __ ] stupid ass fans
god they're dumb
they're so dumb
you just you just
there's like eight percent of them even
remotely unders could even explain a
pick and roll
i gotta tell you if you're not from out
here you gotta come down here and go to
a laker game and just sit amongst them
just to see how [ __ ] dumb they are
god they're dumb
i mean i'm talking like not even summer
school dumb i'm just talking about
[ __ ] learn a trade
drive a truck dumb
right and i know there's people out
there learning a trade right now and i
know what you're thinking what i just
said was insulting and i don't care that
you think that because i know you're too
dumb
to figure out where i where where you
can [ __ ] find me doing stand-up even
though it's on my website
you're just too [ __ ] stupid
i really shouldn't say [ __ ] like that
because there's always one dumb [ __ ] who
takes me seriously do you remember last
week when i was saying how hawaii is not
part of this country
even though it is i'm just saying it
just nobody
nobody um
black or white looks right on that
island you have to be hawaiian
or or asian and you look fine but
we we the rest of us do not look right
on that island
we just don't and then the joke was when
i [ __ ] come here you know
i lean up against the tree i look like
an american like you can't tell me that
and i said i'm so sick of these native
americans complaining if i have to argue
with one more apache it was completely
ridiculous and over the top and
everybody one [ __ ] [ __ ] on twitter
he said bill the reason why you look
normal in this country is because
capital letters you were you killed all
the native americans
it's just like dude arguing with apaches
didn't give it away
there's always going to be that one
[ __ ] person
that just has to [ __ ] take it
seriously
and ruin it for everybody else all right
i'm
am i done whining what else did i do
this week oh
um
what did i do this week
i thought i did something
oh you know what i haven't drank
i haven't drank in uh seven days it's
been a week and i realize now that it is
um
that basically i have to go once i go
seven days and i go and i get past
something like going to a super bowl
party and i don't drink then at that
point i can go a year
like now i could i could go a [ __ ]
it's that first week
where i haven't drank in two days i
haven't drank in three days and i just
think well if i drink i can start over
again i can easily go four days and beat
my streak
once personally once i get seven days in
now i gotta hit the streak going you
know i got the hot bat here i don't want
to end the streak i don't want to start
over again at one
so
i got through the super bowl and it was
brutal
trying to get through it um
oh man we had such a [ __ ] great time
and then in the end right because we
were smoking this pork shoulder and the
last time we we had the temperature too
high and by we i mean lawhead
um this time
we slashed lawhead had it lower and it
took a lot longer which it was totally
worth it but we watched the game in like
two it took us two hours to watch the
game just flew through the whole [ __ ]
thing
and then by the end
of the game the pork roast uh the
was ready
and the pork shoulder i should say was
ready and we just sat there and [ __ ]
chowed down
laughing that we missed all of the
[ __ ]
um
and it was funny nia comes home it's
just like what'd you think of the game
we're like yeah we just finished it blah
blah blah and then she starts talking
about
bruno mars and all that we're like yeah
we didn't see it she's like you didn't
see it
oh my god it was unbelievable it's just
like no
we didn't see it
so then she goes and we recorded the
game she goes and she rewinds it
or fast forwards whatever the [ __ ] she
had to do to get to it i guess we want
rewind yeah because we watched yeah i
hit stop yeah so she had a rewind back
there and she goes to put it on
in la head sitting in my living room and
it comes on and there's this creepy
[ __ ] singing of children
and like
and they're like oh they're backlits all
you see is this silhouettes
and they're singing like
[ __ ] grinch music whatever the [ __ ]
they were singing
sort of holy sort of creepy
that like that pedophile music oh
they're so innocent let's let them sing
innocent creepy [ __ ] church music
right
and i look over at lawhead and i go hey
jay
this is what we miss and jay was over in
the corner and he just [ __ ] looked up
and he just made his face he just goes
but i got to tell you um i actually
watched
i did i then i watched it now that the
game was over i didn't give a [ __ ] and i
actually really liked brutal mars i
watched it
and uh oh what a halftime show that was
that was a tremendous show came out with
the dw green sparkle
played a [ __ ] drum solo oh he was
tremendous what an entertainer did the
james brown's dance
chili peppers came out with their shirts
off i [ __ ] called that
i called it i called it on conan i did
conan this week
i said flea was going to catch a cold
because he wasn't going to wear a shirt
he should be the only one complaining
about the weather
um
so anyway so it was it was [ __ ]
a absolutely phenomenal super bowl
summer sunday and i did not have one
[ __ ] drop of alcohol
and i feel great
and i gotta be honest you not drinking
is uh
it's really hard
right around four o'clock in the
afternoon
till about two in the morning
those 10 hours
are hard the other 14 are easy you know
eight of them i sleep you know
and i just got to get through six hours
but those other ten man i gotta tell you
those are [ __ ] brutal
but i'm a nice little streak here so i'm
gonna try to go until my canadian tour
and then once you know
the canadian tour starts i mean they got
cuban cigars up there they got
it's just gonna be uh
it's gonna be cold
who wants a heater
so whatever so i'm gonna you know what's
funny as i i overheard
somebody who wasn't a doctor
say that um
that basically uh to cleanse your liver
it takes 42 days to cleanse your liver
so like an idiot
i just don't drink for 40 days 42 days
thinking i'm cleansing my liver as i'm
putting in all these [ __ ] you know
i'll eat at mcdonald's
once or i'll [ __ ] just be eating
processed
[ __ ] food i'm not cleansing my liver
but at least i got the alcohol out of
there right i'll drink a little water
with some lemon you know i do what i try
to do but you know
um anyways let's uh let's get to some
advertising this week everybody all
right this this next um advertising is
going to be called uh bill tries to read
on his [ __ ] cell phone here all right
let's let's bring this up all right live
reads
oh jesus will you look who's back
it's our old friends sherry's berries ah
jesus they came back they were good
sports
all right let's read this homo erotic
slash homophobic copy let's see how it
is this time
shari's berries everybody what's the
worst valentine's gift you have ever
been given or received talk about how
much trouble it got you in
being in the dog house oh is that what
i'm supposed to do i'm supposed to make
something up
hey sherry i give i i give great gifts
i hate why advertisers have talk about
how much trouble it got you boy oh boy i
remember one year i got my girlfriend a
lawnmower
what was i thinking
oh jesus um anyways look who's kidding
who you don't have a lot of money just
get him some fruit dumped in chocolate
all right don't make a mistake again
order sherry's berries now for
guaranteed gift satisfaction giant
freshly dripped strawberries from
sherry's berries starting at 19.99
that's at over 40 percent savings like
anybody knows what the market is for
chocolate covered fruit jesus that's
down 40
or double the berries for just ten
dollars more you just need my code burp
e-u-r-r when you order dipped in white
milk and dark chocolatey goodness
topped with chocolate chips i don't know
why this is so funny decorate decorative
swizzle
or nuts
40 percent off from sherry's berries
enormous romantic fresh juicy
mouth-watering berries
please use this time to tell your
listeners about the personal experience
how did the berries taste how did they
look how did your recipe recipients
react
what the [ __ ] is a recipient
rests recipe what the [ __ ] all right all
right [ __ ] it have you ordered berries
for your sweetheart yet here's the only
way to get this amazing valentine's day
deal
giant freshly dipped strawberries
starting at
19.99 or double the berries for just ten
dollars more visit barrys.com please
spell out the word
b-e-r-r-i-e-s dot com click on the
microphone in the top right hand corner
and type in burke go to berries.com
click on the microphone and type in bur
order today
i love that like you're going to get in
trouble for some weird gift but then you
just get him this uh well whatever i got
to stop doing this man i'm going to lose
everybody god knows nature box is not
talking to me anymore
a bunch of babies
uh pro flowers
pro flowers everybody
forgetting valentine's day is as bad as
forgetting her birthday
i debate that i mean they're both bad
but i would say for getting her
birthday's worse
you know remember when i was brought to
this world
um you can't just do it wait you just
can't do it and you can't wait until the
last minute
i'd rather blank than forget valentine's
day hey advertisers i'm not doing the
work for you all right write out the
copy
talk about how much you like flowers oh
jesus i always skipped through him as a
kid i'd rather uh
see peyton manning win a super bowl than
forget valentine's day or even if it's
not for forget it's always wait till the
last minute and then be screwed listen
you guys know the deal all right this is
one of the great gifts you can get for
valentine's day why because it's easy
and it shuts her up get one dozen red
roses with a free glass vase for 30
bucks or upgrade to one dozen red roses
with a premium ruby vase and a and
gourmet chocolates for just 9.99 more
classic romantic red roses with a box of
chocolates there you go sweetheart
and you patter on the ass pro flowers is
quick easy and delivery on valentine's
day is guaranteed you can't beat the
price or the convenience and i i back
that 100
it's about as easy as it can get best
value get it done early choose the
delivery date and check it off the list
even if you already have plans for
valentine's day you still need flowers
delivered which is you have to it's a
must the longer you wait the harder it
will be to find any flowers at this
price
um here's the only way to get this deal
limited time valentine's day deal sorry
one dozen red roses including a free
vase
for 29.99 or you can upgrade to the
premium vase and chocolates for just
9.99 more 40 bucks
40 bucks you make the call
you make the call from a sports bar
while you're drinking with your buddies
ignoring her text
okay that's how convenient this is go to
profile proflowers.com click on the blue
microphone in the top right hand corner
and type in burr burr that's
proflowers.com click on the microphone
and type in bur order now this deal
expires soon
all right
we got two more we'll do those a little
bit later all right
yeah the people at nature's box weren't
happy
why weren't you happy because i said the
obvious just eat a [ __ ] banana
um all right let's get into the
questions for this week how far are we
i'm feeling 40 minutes oh 39 19.
the internal clock of a comedian
um all right los angeles water shortage
hey there billy waterwell
i heard los angeles is going through a
doubt drought
um but what are people doing about it
are people shutting off sprinklers no
they're not
my friend says they still run the
sidewalk sprinklers in his neighborhood
every night unless it rains for a few
nights straight how does this area come
back from something like this
how does uh how's your doomsday bunker
coming along
um
all right
here we go um
yeah well basically
people will run their sprinklers until
the government says hey
don't run them anymore so we haven't
gotten to that point in the drought
where it's
you can't run your sprinklers
so that's why people are still running
them and uh it rained yesterday
so i think we're gonna be all right but
uh i would ask you the same question how
is your doomsday bunker coming along
um personally i don't have one
and i take great comfort in knowing that
i can only die once and that um just
without water i'll be dead within three
days so
i've had an unbelievable
life
i have no desire
to survive the apocalypse
you know
just at the just
at the very basic level the lack of
toilet paper toothbrush and toothpaste
that alone
you know
watching my teeth turning brown
having to slowly yank them out
you know what i mean
the loss of electricity and
listening to your stereo
that alone it's it's just it's not worth
living anymore
you're gonna go back to [ __ ] living
in a clan some goddamn cave or some [ __ ]
i guess the garages will be the new
caves
of the uh i guess of the millennium here
do you know oh you know what after the
uh
after the super bowl was over we all sat
around a dining room table i told you
neil hooked up to stereo because i was
too stupid to figure it out
and uh we put on dark side of the moon
which i have not listened to
wired to wire in years i would arguably
that might be the greatest album of all
time
um
i don't think anything can touch it
can any and you know something i hope
that you got can somebody out there tell
me
and this is a vinyl question
i want to know on album what is there a
better album
to put the headphones on
laying there in the dark
and just listening to that album if
you're young right now and your whole
life has been digital downloads and all
that i i highly urge that you get a
stereo and you buy that
album
and put the [ __ ] lights out and put
the headphones on you got it you have to
experience it like that's
that's you know we were actually a bunch
of old people there you know my age and
a little bit younger and older whatever
and we were talking about how [ __ ]
great the album was because nobody had
heard it in a while
and uh someone there was just sitting
there going like this that's what you
did
like back in the day like
your parents would be like where you
going i'm going upstairs to listen to
music like you you just listened to
music
you weren't on a [ __ ] treadmill
doing night he just i don't i mean you
did listen to the radio in the car or
whatever but it was different you didn't
have like your whole [ __ ] playlist
and bluetooth and talking on the phone
it was it really was it was an activity
like hey man i got the new whatever
record you want to come over and listen
to it and everyone would sit on the
floor and do some drugs man and you'd
put on the [ __ ] album
i missed that i never had that level i
never did the drug thing
um
but uh
i don't know that just made me think of
philip seymour hoffman man what a
[ __ ] tragedy that is huh
jesus christ you know i actually saw him
um
i was dating this wonderful girl and i
[ __ ] it up of course because i'm an
idiot
um
and like the late 1990s
and philip seymour hoffman and john c
riley did a play called true west
and they would switch parts
every other show and uh
i went down with the the woman i was
dating at the time she said you got to
go we got to go see this and i was just
like i don't want to go see some artsy
play right i was too busy doing stand-up
and she's like no you got gotta [ __ ]
see this thing and uh
went down and and got to see both of
them of course were unbelievable
and uh yeah just it's just the [ __ ]
worst
it's the worst if i've learned anything
in this business as i've gained a
respect
for uh addiction
and just
i don't know just how [ __ ] powerful
that is
you know i actually in a way like with
like even like with uh with like booze
like i i'm trying to think the last time
maybe like in november i went longer
than seven days but even then i [ __ ]
up after 10 days
and uh
i was talking to jerome oh man we went
over to derosa's house
apartment the other night
me keith robinson deroza i'm naming a
lot of names here
i usually don't do this [ __ ] but we got
into this [ __ ] debate
i don't want to do this because you guys
are going to blow up joe's [ __ ]
twitter and he gets all [ __ ]
insensitive about that [ __ ] but we uh
me and joe gonna be doing uninformed
again we have to have the debate
it was basically it's centered around
a certain artist
a certain artist and his
uh
unbelievable young wife
and whether or not this person was a
creep or not and oh did it get heated
joe actually got so mad you know like
when you get so mad you're standing up
and you imitate the other person in the
argument while you're doing a dumb dance
like i know what you're going to say oh
what about them he started doing this
dance and everyone started laughing at
him
it was [ __ ] i mean it started at 1am
i i finally had to leave i was like i
have a dog i got to go home okay i gotta
take my dog out
i think i left a little bit after two
and i guess it kept going
um you know of course the next day we
[ __ ] laughed about it but uh
god damn it another [ __ ] great guy
when's the last time well i guess
sometimes somebody who stinks overdoses
that's you know you don't [ __ ] wish
that on anybody but uh
everybody's talking about philip seymour
hoffman's amazing
movies to talk about how great he is how
about how awesome he wasn't twister
that guy was such a great actor he was
even he was even great in twister
i remember the first time i saw him was
in scent of a woman and i just all i
remember was like
who is that actor when he was sitting at
that table and they had whatever the the
council there for the school i can't i
can never remember what the [ __ ]
movies are about
and
it was all the [ __ ] that he was doing
when he wasn't speaking
um
or like in boogie nights
when
how subtly they let you on that his
character was gay
when he was holding on to that clipboard
and he was biting on that pen
the total phallic [ __ ] you know we
came up with that [ __ ]
then i also loved
the way he was standing
in one of those scenes he had like his
right arm was down and then his left arm
was across his body grabbing onto like
his right elbow or vice versa which i
remember was like how many
kids who were really insecure
used to stand like you know when you
were a kid you'd size kids up
and i mean whenever i saw a kid standing
like that i'd be like all right i don't
have to worry about that kid trying to
[ __ ] kick the [ __ ] out of me anybody
who stands like that is the guard i
didn't know that it meant guarded i just
thought it meant like you were a [ __ ]
or something like that but i never saw
an actor make a choice
even though i've seen a zillion human
beings do that i saw him do that in like
uh
boogie nights oh how great he wasn't big
lebowski just everything i've never even
seen capote i'm embarrassed to say that
but uh
it just sucks man he was one of my
favorites that [ __ ] blows all right
that isn't f that isn't funny right
this isn't what this is about this
podcast this podcast is supposed to be
making you laugh get you a great start
to your day
um
all right let's let's continue on here
so in answer to your question sir i have
no plans
for uh for the doomsday um
i'm gonna get a bat
that's what i'm gonna do
[Music]
i'd get a gun but you know
i'm going to shoot it without earplugs
my ears already ring from playing drums
and um
i you know
then what then i win the battle and then
my ears ring even more and i'm walking
around with tinnitus and there's no
[ __ ]
hope for a cure
forget tinnitus i'm just praying for
toothpaste i mean [ __ ] that i don't want
to live
all right sochi is that how you say it
no yogi
uh
billy ssr have you heard
how much the olympics have cost so far 5
billion that's more than the last 12
olympics combined
what do you think all the extra money is
going where do you think all the extra
money is going
um do you have any olympic predictions
um
what i think all the extra money well
they got to make all that snow and
that extra snow in case it doesn't snow
i mean just to cover a mountain in snow
when it hasn't snowed i mean i figured
that's gotta cost at least two billion
right
and you know i know it doesn't i don't
[ __ ] know what i think it went i
think it's uh an unbelievably corrupt
country
even more than one than the one that i
live in so i imagine all the scams that
go on here go on over there because
they're human beings just like us and i
think it's probably even [ __ ]
10 times worse over there because of
where their jump off point was
we at least had a nice phony jump off
point in this country that all men are
equal
and everybody has the freedom to sp of
speech and everybody has the right to
protest and uh no taxation without
representation we had a great [ __ ] we
had a way better lie
than they had in russia
you know
russia's was just hey everybody gets the
same amount of meatloaf man
right
at least from day one
we knew that there was going to be
people gorging off high on the hog and
the rest of us were getting pig feet we
knew that [ __ ] but as long as someone
else was just getting the tail
we were happy in the middle class
and that worked for a long [ __ ] time
and now it's over
um dude how about like these [ __ ] how
about how about
these [ __ ] three major bankers have
killed themselves
in the last week and if we can get past
well bad things happen in trees
um
that scares the [ __ ] out of me
i'm not gonna lie to you those guys were
probably all making seven
to eight figures i would think
and they [ __ ] off themselves
and there's no sign that a woman was
involved that broke their hearts or
you know
i just that that is scary
were they going to go rogue and say what
was really going on
are they just looking at that ponzi
scheme and just thinking like yeah
there's just there's no way to fix it
the wolves are at the door
i'm going to be the oswald i'm going to
be the fall guys so they [ __ ] i mean
that's just insane what are the odds
what are the odds of that when was the
last time
like three major oil people all killed
themselves within the same week for the
love of god can i get some conspiracy
theory on this one i would love to hear
your theories
i'd love to hear
you know
because that's the kind of guy i am
um
all right where are we let's get on to
the next thing here
long distance hiking follow-up all right
here we go hey bill a few weeks ago you
asked for advice on how to deal with
animals in the wilderness most people
that get mauled either left food in
their oh yeah that's why i have this
massive fear
about going into the woods
and accident accidentally stumbling upon
a uh
a mama bear with their cubs
or a uh a mountain lion
i'm always on a trail and to the left or
the right of me is a higher like like
cliff and the thing is just sitting
there
you know you know when they sit there
and they put their head down and their
[ __ ] shoulder and back muscles go
like [ __ ]
like if they were in a muscle
competition like that would be like the
schwarzenegger like stance they put
their head down you know what i'm saying
just waiting to pounce on me
um this is what the person says most
people get mauled either uh most people
that get mauled either left food in
their tent
or tried to pose for a picture with the
animal or did some other dumb [ __ ] you
would never do but yes on very rare
occasions an animal will attack somebody
who did nothing wrong here is my advice
if that happens first of all you did do
something wrong you ventured out into
the wilderness
you left the tribe you put yourself at
risk
all right i mean i guess if you're in
your backyard and there's a bear there
but if there's a bear in your backyard
you
that's urban sprawl that when
he's not in your backyard you're in his
front yard
there's no [ __ ] reason a bear should
be outside your house
you need to move back down towards the
village all right there auntie social
get a hobby
say hello to somebody
you know have a couple of drinks get
some alcohol courage in you and go walk
up to the pretty girl and say hello okay
stop trying to live with the [ __ ]
owls
all right
bears uh if you're attacked by a bear
you should leave your backpack on to
protect your back
and use your hands to cover your neck
what about your face
usually the bear will leave after a
while but if it starts to chew on you
that's when you need to fight back
oh really what what should i go with
should i set up the you know the
overhand right with a couple of jabs
or should i try to kick him in his uh
bear balls what if it's a woman
what do i do
do i try to stick my toe in its vag
it's bear vag it's badge
mountain lions
with mountain lions playing dead will
not work you need to fight back right
away
your best chance is to aim for the nose
and eyes
dude this is [ __ ] hilarious
i mean i i think i would have a this is
none of this [ __ ] work wouldn't work
against mike tyson forget about a
[ __ ] bear or a mountain lion wolves
playing dead won't work in a wolf attack
either
you can either climb a tree
put it in a headlock
or shove your fist down its throat i'm
not joking look it up
you know what i always thought you could
do a i don't know about a wolf i always
thought against this was my
you know when i'm laying in bed and i'm
thinking about getting attacked
by a [ __ ] you know some rabid dog or
whatever
if somebody sick that dog on me
when i'm laying in bed
totally relaxed and have my wits about
me and i don't have urine running down
my leg as i run towards my prius
like i would in real life
[Music]
i um
my plan of attack was when the [ __ ]
dog is coming at you you stick your
forearm out and you just feed it to him
you just jam it
right into his [ __ ] mouth
and right as it clamps down and it has
you you then take your other [ __ ]
forearm and you come up over the top
smash down on the top of the thing's
neck
as you push your forearm up and you
break its neck
you go bam crap
which is the sound of a broken neck flap
i'm sorry i don't want to make the snap
noise i don't have a twig in here
that's that was my game plan
either that or just stick your arm in
there and you just you just [ __ ]
start stepping on the dog's feet
because dogs are kind of [ __ ] man
they'll go after you but the second you
[ __ ] do something back to you you
know what it is they don't have any
shame
they don't mind going
and then getting hit and then going yay
oh my god what the [ __ ] like they don't
give a [ __ ]
it's not like other dogs are gonna they
can literally do that and then go on the
other side of the block and get laid
there's like no
and they don't even remember what just
happened unless there's still pain in
their little dog paw
so um
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know what
i'm talking about here these these are
all like
these are all creepy [ __ ] questions
i always felt if i was on a boat and i
saw an alligator swimming towards one of
my friends
and it went by the boat or a shark i
would just
try to time it where i jump down and i
just [ __ ] land right on its head and
i just figured that that alone would so
freak it out they would leave or
you know the shark or alligators would
be uh would be feasting on two people
that's what i would worry about after
the show after this shock
you know when the shark's like what the
few [ __ ] when it's coming back
that's why i think like sharks i think
just leave alligators they just seem
[ __ ] relentless to me
um all right killer bees here we go
with killer bees africanized honeybees
you're supposed to run away for at least
half a mile now this i know do not flail
your arms
and do not kill one
they will swarm you if you kill one but
honestly
they they look just like normal bees to
me so i don't know how to tell when
you're in danger
oh my god run for a half a mile
for [ __ ] half a mile what's the
fastest fastest mile i ever ran was like
a 6 18 like freshman year
in high school when i weighed about 140
something pounds i'm now a buck 75
so i think i could run maybe a seven
minute
even with the fear just the pain is
gonna
offset the adrenaline
that's gonna be a long 15 minutes people
oh god can you imagine me
a balding stung up [ __ ] swollen
redhead
just coming over the hill jesus christ
what a sight all right spiders kill
almost nobody most can be very dangerous
if you catch them at the wrong time some
snake bites obviously require immediate
medical care but i would be more afraid
of lightning if i were you so yes it can
get gruesome but these attacks are very
rare absolutely i mean i know shark
attacks are very rare but it's just like
i would love to try surfing but just you
know just the fact that you know
you understand that surfing is a sport
where you're risking getting eaten alive
i mean it's just [ __ ] i mean it's
just not worth it
goddammit it looks like fun though
doesn't it
all right basic travel advice oh wait
you know i got to read some more uh
advertising here before i get on with
this [ __ ] [ __ ] over yeah uh live
reads all right we got two more
everybody
two more two more two more
all right hulu plus
hulu plus everyone you've probably tried
hulu.com now with hulu plus you can
watch your favorite shows anytime
anywhere hulu plus lets you watch
thousands of hit tv shows and a
selection of acclaimed movies on your
television or on the go with your
smartphone or tablet
and it all streams in hd for the best
viewing experience possible with hulu
plus you can watch your favorite current
tv shows like saturday night live
community and family guy you can also
check out exclusive content including
hulu originals like the awesome starring
snl seth myers and moon boy starring
chris o'dowd from bridesmaids hulu plus
also offers a great selection of
acclaimed films for only 7.99 a month
you can stream as many tv shows and
movies as you want wherever you want
right now you can try hulu plus for free
for two weeks when you go to
huluplus.com
bill that's a special offer for my
listeners make sure you use huluplus.com
bill so you get the extended free trial
and they know that i sent you go to
huluplus.com bill now or click on the
hulu plus banner on the podcast page at
billberg.com
and last but certainly not least the
classic
stamps.com everyone if you haven't heard
yet postage rates
have changed again
because basically the post office is
slowly going out of business
uh so don't get caught up in their awful
business uh you know what that means the
post office is even more crowded than
usual that's why you need stamps.com
with stamps.com you'll eliminate those
time-consuming trips to the post office
everything you can do at the post office
you can do right now from your own desk
buy and print official us postage for
any letter or package using your own
computer or printer and stamps.com
always up updates the postage rates for
you automatically so you always get the
exact postage you need the instant you
need it you don't even have to think
plus you'll never have to go to the post
office again i personally have been
using stamps.com for almost three years
it's so convenient and so easy even a
[ __ ] like me knows how to use it right
now use my last name bur for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
so don't wait go to stamps.com right now
before you do anything else and click on
the microphone on the top of the home
page and type in bur b-u-r-r that's
stamps.com enter burr oh i lied there's
one more e-voice
last but not least by the way i'm
[ __ ] crushing these reads
e-voice everybody you're a business
owner but automated phone systems and
secretaries aren't in your budget just
yet and juggling incoming calls yourself
makes it hard to look like a
professional here's something that will
dramatically help you make more money in
2014 what is it it's e-voice whether
you're on whether you're a business of
one or one hundred e-voice will help you
manage all of your incoming phone calls
uh with a toll-free number dial by name
directory and call routing tools your
business will sound like a million
dollars
can't take a call evoice will transcribe
the voicemail and email and email it
straight to you never get caught off
guard again and with e-voice you can try
it before you buy it right now
just for my listeners you can get a
60-day free trial to e-voice go to
evoice.com and enter the promo code bill
and check
at checkout take charge of your business
and make more money in 2014 go to
evoice.com and enter bill at the
checkout for your 60-day free trial
that's evoice dot com promo code bill
see that i talked a little bit of [ __ ]
and then i [ __ ] up a lot on the last
one but still much better than the uh
than the past there all right let's
continue on here
um all right basic travel advice
uh good morning to our fearless leader
sir billiard of bald
uh
i am 24 i'm a 24 year old and me and the
wife are taking a trip to chicago
wanted some advice on a couple of things
neither of us has ever planned on uh has
ever been on a plane before you are a
frequent flyer so i wanted to know
exactly what we can expect at the
airport when to be there what close to
prepare to take off at what time
problems we will mostly
most likely run into etc
jesus christ dude um
all right well go ahead and pack and
then take a third of that stuff and
throw it over your [ __ ] shoulder
because you're never gonna wear it
um
depending on how long you're leaving if
it's just a weekend i would go with the
carry-on if it isn't i would check
everything
walk onto the plane with a couple of
magazines and order a drink
and watch and just enjoy watching
everybody else fighting
you know
for that overhead space [ __ ] them
um that would be my advice
and also just know that your wife is
gonna bring half the [ __ ] house and
it's not worth telling her that she's
not gonna need it all right
um
the only thing worse than having to pay
for extra bags is watching her cry that
there's nothing to wear and then having
to go downstairs to the [ __ ] lobby
mall there and pay 10 times the price to
get her a [ __ ] dress
all right number two
best places to eat there
best burger slice of pizza personal
favorite two i would like to add that i
am milk white and redheaded like you so
a place that is not in this
stabby stabby muggy muggy part of town
would be preferred
really wanting some advice from an
experienced vet thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
um i don't know where the best places
are to eat in chicago like i visit there
and i just eat at the closest place and
then i go and do my show
um according to jim crotche the south
side the south side of chicago is the
baddest part of town
um but if you go down there you better
best be aware of a man named leroy brown
and um
i believe he has a custom continental
and he has a cadillac too
he got a 32 gun in his pocket for fun he
got a razor in issue right on and he's
bad bad um i don't know where to [ __ ]
eat there all i know is that uh what you
should do you can find all of that out
on a website one of those foodie [ __ ]
websites they'll tell you where to go
um
so but those foodie things can be wrong
a lot of the times what you want to do
is ask a local
wherever you stay
just find somebody who has a heavy
chicago accent and just say listen i'm a
tourist i don't want to go to the
touristy place where do you go to get
whatever the [ __ ] you're looking for you
want a pizza you want a burger and that
guy will tell you
all right that's the way to do it okay
here we go
all right uh
oh by the way you know i forgot to
mention when i saw that drum clinic the
common thread one there was a musician
there
uh drew of a band called drew
of the drew
um if you like
not mainstream music and you'd like to
see somebody who's really trying to do
something different uh check that guy
out
um i was i was very uh
very impressed it made me feel old like
they would they were drawing from [ __ ]
that like
to me i already considered like new
music
like all that dj dubstep [ __ ] like to me
is like came out in the last six months
even though it's probably been around
for [ __ ] 20 years
um
anyways drew of the drew check it out um
anyways
gino phobia maybe i'll i'll put up i'll
put up a link actually hey billy bo
baggins
is it gynophobia
are you afraid of the gynecologist i
don't [ __ ] know i am a 20 year old
college guy who has
was it gynophobia
the fear of women
i've never heard of this
uh he said when i was a kid i used to
get the [ __ ] kicked out of me and girls
would always spread rumors about me and
it would really screw with my mind
wait a minute you didn't get along with
men or women
what were you doing
you know what that's the last thing you
needed to hear what's wrong with you
i'm sorry
forgive me i'm not a trained
professional so you know you're asking
them more on and you know i'm gonna
behave
accordingly here we go as i grew up i
started to resent and hate all the
people around me
that my mother tells me about false rape
accusations
and that makes oh and that makes females
look even more scarier
than they already were
see guys just kick the [ __ ] out of you
females psychologically [ __ ] you up bad
and don't even have a tint
of remorse or empathy
oh jesus christ
all right dude so your mother's a psycho
and she put all these fears on you yeah
you gotta maybe i would seek some
professional help before you turn into
norman bates
uh all right let's continue this then i
hear about all the women raping men in
the divorce courts and in general adding
more fuel to the fear dude
you're overthinking this [ __ ] i mean you
probably heard half of that from me but
i'm an idiot don't listen to me he says
gotten to the point where
when a female introduces herself to me i
just see her as a potential mind raping
and prolonged exercise of getting
verbally abused so i just always say
sorry but i have somewhere to be right
now goodbye
and i walk away sir can i steal that
from you
i want to use that next time i get
pulled over
okay license resident sorry but i have
somewhere to be right now goodbye
and you just just act like the rain man
and they'll [ __ ] leave you alone
that's actually brilliant
uh he said they scare me so much but i'm
still attracted to them oh my god dude
listen you gotta you gotta
you gotta get past this
hopefully you're still young and this is
early on but this is something where you
are
you know
everybody is trying to go towards the uh
we'll just call it uh whatever planet
live happily ever after but if you're
off by just one degree
you're not really going to notice when
you're 22 24 you know but by the time
you're 40 you're going to be about a
million miles off course so let's try to
get you some help
i would go see a therapist sir
um and i know i've been joking around
but i kind of have to do that because
this is a podcast
but um
well actually because it's a podcast
that's supposed to be funny um not
saying you can't have a serious podcast
um
yeah i would go get some help
quickly and i would get rid of all those
fears and i would say a lot of the fears
are probably uh
put into your head by your mom when
you're really young and you need to try
to get those out of there before they
take any more route than they already do
uh i already have
well let's finish here he said my mind
says stay the [ __ ] away while my dick
says do it do it [ __ ] do it uh but in
this climate of unrestrained female
hypo agency and what the [ __ ] i mean the
[ __ ] that makes women invade male spaces
and makes them change everything to suit
them dude dude
you're taking your [ __ ] fear of women
you're me
you're blowing by me
listen are you a great guy if you're a
great guy there's a great woman out
there for you
and then and it's a beautiful thing
they're not all like this what you're
doing is you're taking the worst of the
worst of females and you're painting it
with the broad brush
all right um
oh jesus christ i'm relating to this guy
here he said i'd rather stay celibate
for life all right no i don't relate to
that i am a loner to a vast degree but i
got a loving family to back me up so i
ain't on the fringe or anything i plan
on just working towards my career and
did i write this like 20 years ago jesus
christ
plan on just working towards my career
in education but either way i'll have to
deal with women
and it's been hard to do since lately
do so lately since my social skills
tanked over the last
nine months
trauma conga line of horrific events
happened and i am working on getting the
confidence back through brazilian jiu
jitsu i already lost 11 pounds and i'm
starting to feel a lot better all right
well just don't go choke out any women
all right or try to put him in the
triangle he said anyways is there any
way but martial arts are a great way to
build self-esteem from what i've heard
anyways is there any is there any way to
get rid of the insane fear i have about
women or is it just 15 years of hurt
that'll take almost forever to undo
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself six ways
from sunday
and good luck with your stand up um
all right oh so you're only 15 is that
what you're saying
all right dude
first of all it's great you took up
brazilian jiu jitsu you should know how
to defend yourself and uh don't be a
[ __ ] about it when you become a black
belt
use it to save nerds and protect
yourself but never be a bully
and then as far as women i would
actually try and talk to somebody about
this
and i would try to have more of an open
mind because right now if you're only 15
years old or even if you're young in
your early 20s mid-20s you're basically
you got the lottery pick as far as women
goes
all right
they're all available all first-round
draft picks bunch of first-round draft
picks just sitting there
and you know depending on when you open
your mouth and start talking to one is
when you pick in the draft if you know
what i mean sooner rather than later but
i would just talk to somebody about um
about about some of your issues
maybe at school they got some free
[ __ ] therapy or something like that
if you're too young to pay for it
but um
i don't know i would talk to somebody i
would talk to some of your guy friends
about it
i would you know what i would do i would
openly talk about your fear of women
to um
to friends
you know and i would i would sit down
with your mother and just say listen
i have major issues with women right now
and i think some of it stems from a lot
of the negative things that you've said
about them and i need you to stop doing
that because it's it's [ __ ] with me
don't don't say that part but say it in
a nicer way
um but if she's you know
i don't know
that's the hardest [ __ ] thing is
because you are born into the religion
of your parents
you know and into all of their beliefs
and hopefully they have more good than
bad but they're human so they're gonna
be wrong
and you know when you're a little
toddler all the way through like seven
eight years old your parents are godlike
you just think they know everything and
they have all the answers they never
look unsure you do everything that they
[ __ ] say
so a lot of that stuff just really takes
deep root like
it's it's law in your head
and
then in your teenage years you start
breaking away you realize some of it's
[ __ ] and that's when some anger can
come out and that type of stuff so
i would say what you're going through is
normal
it's just that you maybe had an extreme
uh helping of
some [ __ ] anti-woman [ __ ]
which i can relate to because i did too
and i had to fight through that [ __ ] i
mean it took man to get married until i
was 45.
i had major [ __ ] issues but uh it's
like anything
look it just use the martial arts thing
as a uh
metaphor or a simile whatever the [ __ ]
you're supposed to whatever the right
terminology is
look you you did that you stuck with
that you lost 11 pounds you work towards
that look at look at what you're you're
getting you're getting positive results
and it hasn't been easy right but you
keep showing up you get positive results
i would do the same thing with your
women issues i would just start working
on it
um
you know next time a woman comes up and
says hello don't say i have somewhere to
go just say hello back and stay in the
conversation for as long as you can and
when you feel like bailing just say
listen i'm really shy around women and
it's something that i'm trying to work
on just put it out there and you know
what i guarantee eighty percent of them
are gonna say
oh
you know when they do that they're gonna
love it and next thing you know you're
out there watching a romantic comedy
with some lady having a good time but i
would i would address it sooner than
later i'm telling you dude it's you
literally it's
you think it's a mountain it's it's a
[ __ ] it's stepping up under the curb
it's all in your head and that's totally
normal because i i would guess that your
fears started
when you were in your my mom's god-like
phase of your life so you think you
think it's uh
what's that [ __ ] mountain everybody
everest that everybody tries to climb up
it isn't it isn't okay it's a little
[ __ ] ant hill and you can do it all
right i believe in you good luck sir
there you go well that's the podcast for
this week
um congratulations to the um
to the seattle seahawks
all right
you finally won
you [ __ ] won the super bowl and now i
can't give you any more [ __ ]
actually i still will just stop doing
that loudest crowd ever right you got
the [ __ ] trophy you've been there now
act like you've been there before do not
disappoint me next year you know it's go
you know it's coming next year you know
it is there's going to be so many people
dressed up like characters you're going
to make the raider fans
i don't even know what the expression is
i don't know what happened jesus christ
whatever happened to that raider fan
base
that crushes me every time they pan to
the end zone
everybody's out there somebody dressed
like fred flintstone it's like what are
you doing
um all right that's the podcast oh by
the way and i forgot to i've been
watching actually i watched a bunch of
hockey this week because of uh
you know i didn't watch watch any of the
super bowl hype but gee oh jesus
with that bruins performance against the
canadians jesus
christ how do you not get up for a game
against the canadians i know the
canadians have a good team but jesus
christ we look [ __ ] horrific
um
but it's good though it's all good
canadians have a good team so hopefully
we'll meet each other in the playoffs
playoffs
and uh we'll have another classic
that's what i'm hoping for so uh all
right that's it i'm at where the hell am
i this week i'm going to be
in a casino in uh outside of minneapolis
it's already sold out so thank you to
everybody in davenport and every other
goddamn city out there in minnesota
and i can't wait to get out there
hopefully it doesn't [ __ ] snow
you